hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the joy of creation
story mode now we're gonna be going into
the office and if I had to guess based
on the monitor in the van there it's
going to be a lot like the original
office in five nights at freddys
originally but then again I don't know
because apparently this is in Scott so
for years I've thought that what I saw
was just a bad dream something they
couldn't possibly have been real why
would it monstrous beings coming to get
a helpless child from the shadows poking
their heads out from under the bed
peeking through the closet just a usual
nightmare for a kid right no matter how
real it felt well most of what came
after his foggy felt more like a dream
than the actual nightmare itself mom
came to rescue me picked me up and
carried me away I was scared for my life
it was the scariest moment of my life
for sure I've never been a crybaby
though even when I was a kid people told
me they've never seen me cry or yell or
even scream so even if I was terrified
during all of it I would have been
silent the entire time but that was the
strangest thing about that night even
though I never made a peep as I was
being taken outside by my mother away
from the nightmare I still vividly
remember hearing my own screams hmm well
that's weird maybe you're not such a
badass child as you thought you might be
all right Nick
[Music]
happening real okay
just dreaming is real okay whoa hi hello
oh that's that bad okay weird terrified
what is this help somebody help help
Nick Anthony Sam where are you
[Music]
behind you what's going on
oh never mind then yes safe in the
office just hide there for a few hours
for the month
yeah that's weird
good thing they wrote you a really nice
cursive note for you in your office
okay woz to move space to stand up or
sit down left-click to interact with
objects in your office okay so it's
gonna be free roam again a little bit
[Music]
but these messages buy something to to
remember to help me remember what they
do how they act I mean that they all
want to get inside but I've only managed
to give the camera so far but I can
watch the animatronics coming in here
these three monitors three entrances
they haven't come in awhile but I know
they'll be back soon they become an
impatient louder faster especially
especially foxy
he's uh he's the one who's been in
torment to get the pasta I don't know
where he comes from
I don't know how but he just appears
near Annapolis growls and scrapes I just
watch him through the cameras and he
eventually goes away stands there he
knows I don't fully understand get out
of here I need to find God I just I just
I can't stay put here for my family he's
gone
this might be suicide but I need to try
if I see Freddie again I'll just open up
the door and flash his eyes as soon as
he's there he has I can't let him hold
me down like this forever
it just hope this works out if it
doesn't and I kids if you are hearing
this I love you you're safe
okay well this I don't know any of this
I don't understand any of this I don't
know any of this
I don't get it I don't know why I need
to check the drawers I don't know I need
to check the whole wall I can't do it
anymore oh there we go
I don't know I need to flash I don't
know I don't know I don't know what I
picked up I picked up a piece of some
frickin dick what is going on here why
do I need to look at all the trash cans
honestly though really oh that doesn't
sound good okay
oh ah
Boxey well hey hi okay well then alright
that's weird
no about that no about that okay that's
bizarre don't know why you're doing none
of that well okay well I guess I'm just
gonna be sitting around till I die cuz I
know I'm not gonna get through this on
the first try I know that for a goddamn
cracked at least I need to stare it foxy
through the monitors that Oh whose whose
a-knockin
whoa who's that that foxy eyes foxy I
don't need to worry about you Heisey
alright that's good
back to God I don't know it's just so
horrifying she just wrinkles fries back
and forth trying to get out of there
know how to stop her though she shows up
sometimes anyway they just up here if I
flash them with the light [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] someone's at my
window get up get up get up get up
oh hi okay did I get old not all of them
apparently get out of here oh no oh oh
oh I don't know what I'm going for
what's like I get out of here
Freddie bastard oh I don't know what to
do about you where was it was there
another one anywhere I don't remember
where anything we're all is oh boy
that's that's not good oh there you were
okay ganya apparently oh I don't know
how does he do this I don't know how to
do this I think I know about it don't
really know oh my god oh hey foxy how
you doing okay alright then that's nice
oh excuse you somebody there
uh-huh it is so weird uh-huh
it's so weird I've never seen anything
like this what's really amazing is that
all these nights are different different
oh oh that's bad okay well who's there
who was there someone was there who
appeared oh that's a cupcake okay no
don't what that oh you get out of here
and then I'm gonna get the cupcake okay
cool
getting up now gonna get the cupcake in
the doorway at that like ah okay okay oh
look in here no no luck okay ha ha
holster nope no such luck
[Music]
this is horrible it's horrible this is
horrible
oh this horrible who's there hey oh boy
there's a dozen cupcakes Oh what I'm
Farber knocked I'm Farber knock that's
down now forever hi okay where's the
last cupcake I don't know where where's
our last cupcake on I don't know where
in here Oh God
oh god that's good okay I hear okay I
heard that apparently Jesu that's down
forever apparently a foxy oh boy well
got a mystery patient out here no one
all right great
how about here anybody well that's not
good there's Bonnie hmm interesting
how about here no oh good writhing
crybabies here
that's not good oh that's not good at
all
hi okay hello okay so the last one's
gonna be oh boy well it's gonna be soon
oh well that was guesswork that was pure
and simple guesswork oh boy who do you
got
hi okay you're there okay good get up
get up get off get off get up that's not
good hello foxy that's not what I wanted
hello oh boy I'm doing amazingly for my
first try but you know I still don't
think I'm gonna make this okay I don't
know what the [ __ ] okay well good thing
you're coming the bad one is pure
unadulterated Locke who that nope not
looking at that okay well there's chica
again that's great to know
can I look through here is Bonnie still
there okay you're there but now you're
gone get out of here you please don't be
foxy
Oh get that okay I have a funny feeling
well that was bad cuz I was down a
camera but I was close but for first try
not bad not bad for a first ride oh hey
well was that double duty yep that got
both of them okay so the best policy in
my opinion looking for the little guy
outside first and dealing with that one
oh where are you where you heard a roar
off to the left let's see if that
actually coincided with anything
go with the no okay uh hello
wait how are you still wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait what Chi guys
done I fine
took care of you I did I swear I did oh
boy I did I did I did I got the one
outside I got everything I got
everything I got all of it what are you
still doing writhing I don't understand
oh that's not good that's the opposite
of good there's I did I flogged it by
getting a twofer no they're off the left
what are you well that's [ __ ]
oh okay yeah look at her that didn't
help me I [ __ ] see again oh hi oh I just
saw in the other
[Music]
oh no no chicken no no no no chicken oh
okay okay that's gone okay I need to
find Oh God the [ __ ] is happening okay
foxy no no no foxy no no cat me oh come
on
Oh goddamn yeah yeah what the [ __ ]
happened what the [ __ ] happened
well like that the [ __ ] is that about
[Music]
hey no I know what happened
Georgia [ __ ] you [ __ ] you wait did I do
it god damn it I know that I knew that I
knew that oh I knew that
[Music]
whoa okay did I do it I think I did it
yes okay cancelled new fan app game
stopping production Scott Cawthon
announces the cancellation of the fifth
entry in the popular game series five
nights at freddy's fans are torn at the
sudden news I didn't think I actually
did that I was so concentrated how shall
flow hist how stressful that's a think
about these they're stressful like
they're all so different like the
mechanics are completely unique across
the board here which I can really
appreciate but man is it stressful I
can't imagine what a hard mode of this
would be oh damn button so anyway that
is the end of the office that was a
[ __ ] next up is the basement okay so is
it gonna end in the Attic or something I
guess
so either way thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
think down the comments below and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]